It turns out that sunlight doesn't just do
bad things, like cause DNA damage but it
also does many good things, one of which
is that it stimulates vitamin D production. So here
is a molecule that resides in cells in
your epidermis. It's 7-dehydrocholesterol. And simply getting UV
rays from the sun causes the chemistry, right?
I mean this is real energy. Energy's being absorbed
by this molecule. And it is structurally changing,
it is chemically changing into Vitamin D3. Now this
is obviously a good thing because your body
needs Vitamin D. But the more melanin you produce,
the more light it absorbs and so the
less UV light is available for this conversion process
to vitamin D. So, if you have too much
melanin in regions with too little sunlight, then you're
not going to get enough light to produce enough vitamin
D. So as humans migrated away from the equator
and into regions with less sunlight, the darker pigment
prevented enough good sunlight from stimulating this vitamin D
production. And as a result there were some mutations
that produced less melanin and they were selected for
to allow more sunlight back into the cell. Just
enough sunlight so they could get some vitamin D3 but
not so much sunlight that it's causing a heavy mutation burden. One allele that
was selected for in an environment with less UV rays is an SNV contained in the
tyrosinase coding region on chromosome 11. Here's
the original sequence. And here's the variant sequence.
I want you to identify the would be codon with the mutation by selecting which
region you think it's in here. And then determine the
type of coding region mutation that it is by selecting
silent, missense, or nonsense. Remember, use your genetic code if
you need it. It's in the instructor's notes in this page.